[Applause]  around the screen  ste oak inspector Murray Murray pulls  the trigger  they're gonna do no timeouts 90 86  nuggets  [Applause]  [Music]  you're all set  [Applause]  the truck goes  turns a triple-double  whoops 15 rebounds 10 assists  time is running out on the Smurfs  [Applause]  I'm going to advance to the Western  Conference semifinals to let the  Portland Trail  yes we've got pandemonium at Pepsi  Center  [Applause]  folks that was a a young team tried to  hold on  and it wasn't pretty but if not sure  that you wanted any other  oh my god  [Applause]  tailgate party going crazy the youngest  team in the NBA playoff says hello we're  going to the western conference semis  they beat the Spurs in the playoffs for  just the second time ever Scotty stands  they don't do it like hockey where you  got the guys skating in the middle but  there was every member of Bolton every  comes a bulky  [Applause]  the poteen fought their hearts